Hi, everyone. My name's Tamara Chambers, and this is Tamara Just Saw
I went and saw a hit man's bodyguard, solo, today. Cody is doing comedy in another state
So I went to see hit man's bodyguard which is about a Hitman who needs a bodyguard
All right, we're done here. It was fine, guys. It was- There were funny moments.
It had good action
The cinematography was pretty. It looked good. The script was weak. It felt like any other
kind of action film that I've ever seen. Ryan Reynolds has a really great sense of
joking for deadpool. It really works for that character to always be on and always be joking and I think that's why he's just
Perfect as deadpool. It doesn't work for every other character that he's going to play and it was it
It was a similar vibe. The character was written as kind of like this uptight
kind of
like "by the books" guy
But then with Ryan Reynolds like always throwing in his kind of joke style it felt, just, kind of like... like funny
Good moments, but also super clashing against what the character is supposed to be. Samuel L. Jackson was amazing this role was written
Specifically for him. He was very funny his comedy made sense in the role. It just didn't work for me with Ryan Reynolds
With his comedy style. Again, he was very funny in it, just the character wasn't supposed to be that way
I don't know how to say her name salma Hayek salma Hayek also
Played Samuel L. Jackson's wife and she was
So funny. This is my favorite movie I've seen her in. I don't know that I've seen her in much
But she really hit the character just very well. She was written really funny
As like... the story in a whole it was... it was a cute story. I feel like I've seen it before
The biggest disappointment story wise though was the love story between Ryan Reynolds and his
Ex-Wife or
Ex-fiance I guess spoilers. I don't know it's not like
You know a harry potter movie where it's going to ruin everything for you. This is just what happens in the film.
Is...He... Ryan Reynold's character gets upset at his ex-wife
Because he messes up this job
And he thinks she's the one who kind of sold him out on the job and ended up being Samuel L. Jackson. Which is very like
"Of course", but he blames her so much for something that she didn't do that
They have to separate and then halfway through the movie he decides to forgive her which doesn't go well obviously. Then at the end he
Finally like fully says "I'm sorry" for it then they get back together immediately. And it just feels very
"Blah!" like they don't have any chemistry like in Deadpool the...the lady he was with in Deadpool
(I don't know anyone's names) but they had such good chemistry together that it just felt so good and perfect and
Real. This just was like
"I don't care about you guys as a couple it also doesn't really matter to me if you get together again"
You know what I mean? Is that harsh? That's a little harsh, sorry. Like I said though. I really enjoyed Samuel  L. Jackson's
part in this. He had some great lines.
"I am Harm's way. I am harm's way, Same, I'm harm's way.
Samuel L Jackson also sings in the film a couple times and at one point
It's really touching, as he's doing it for his wife, another part is he's doing it to annoy
Ryan Reynolds character and again another character thing with Ryan Reynolds. Ryan Reynolds starts singing and it's just very out of...
Because he's sitting there mad that he's singing like he wants to keep quiet and everything orderly, but then to annoy Samuel L. Jackson
He starts loudly singing it just doesn't feel like something that is character would do, and if somebody else was playing it
Maybe could have pulled it off but Ryan reynolds is such a funny... trying to be funny (which normally, usually, does well with) but
this was just it felt like I was watching Ryan Reynolds play deadpool play this kind of
tight-ass
Bodyguard. It was weird. The character of Samuel L. Jackson is
Driven by the love of his wife and just really
sweet that it just comes down to that the whole movie really for him his motivation is is the love of his wife to
where one point he risks his life in the whole mission just to put some flowers in a
vantage point where she'll see from her jail cell. She's in jail, as well, and at the beginning
They're like we'll pardon your wife if you help us with this mission, and he's like oh
You'll pardon my wife who has done nothing wrong
That's some white shit. It's just really funny. He calls people out in a good way
He's really tough, but it just it comes down to love for him. To the point where Ryan Reynolds, and it was like
"Why is it always love with you?" He's like, " Well, what else is there?"
It's really good, and I just the... the difference of how I loved these characters is so crazy
I really really loved samuel Jackson. And Ryan Reynolds... I take it or leave it
It's weird because I think if it would have been another
Person cast other than Ryan Reynolds. I don't think the movie would have done as well
I think they had good chemistry together: Ryan Reynolds and samuel L. jackson. Especially towards the end
But there were just weird joke moments that just didn't work
there's kind of
Like that's not what your character would do
Deadpool look great, but just be something else
You need to get Simon Pegg in here
He'll show us a different character. Also the main bad guy is pretty forgettable as well
I really wasn't invested at all in that portion of the story just felt like
Like I said before just like any other action film that I've ever seen, really it's about these two men
Having to work together when one of them is trying to kill the other like
27- 28 times it's more about that
and
Then you get this side story of the love and the love and you get the side side story of like the evil bad guys
So in that respect, it's fine and it works, because they have good chemistry together
but
The main like, chunk, of like the... where the action comes from and like why they're doing this for this...
Like "rid the world of this bad guy", just is
Boring, I don't care that much. So the one part where Ryan Reynolds is like. "I forgive you" to his ex-fiancee
For something that she didn't do
Samuel L. Jackson is like. "How did that go buddy? Women don't like to be forgiven for something because it implies
They did something wrong." and like seven guys behind me
gave like uh... like a low bro chuckle. Like a uh-huh huh huh
like in unison
I mean it's true. Really cool setting though in amsterdam
They really used like the canal ways and the waterways, and it was really exciting. I've also been there. So that was cool
I know this place. It's like when I get a movie reference that I used to not get. I just kept
Comparing it to deadpool. The whole time while watching it
Ryan Reynolds, I really haven't seen him in anything other than deadpool this and then like some
romantic comedies
I
Think I didn't see green lantern
Think cody and I are going to do a Tamra's never seen of Green Lantern soon. I think
I really enjoyed some of the acting in the movie. The chemistry between
Samuel L. Jackson and Salma Hayek, and then Samuel L. Jackson and Ryan Reynolds really worked. I
Didn't find the chemistry between Ryan and his ex-wife to work very well, but I liked her in the film. How the story was very
"Blah!" Like it's fun. It's... it's an action movie. It's pretty
There are definitely funny moments. This isn't a movie that you have to see in theaters
I don't think? I think you could probably... I could watch this at home
I think I would have enjoyed it more. I liked Ryan Reynolds in this I just his charm that he puts on
Didn't really work for me in this. Versus where it soooo works in Deadpool
And I think I'm being a little harsh on him as well. He's... I
enjoy him on screen, but
I don't know for some reason it just didn't connect with me in this one, and that's okay, that's fine
Things happen. Oh, it's got a thirty five percent on rotten tomatoes, okay?
Okay, that's good to see. I was worried. I was going a little harsh on it. It's okay
It's an ok film like I said watch it at home
I don't think you need to go out to the theaters to see this one the best part of it is watching Samuel  L. Jackson who
really hits his character well, kind of interact with other people in the film. There's some really funny things with
authority figures that he kind of clashes heads with  and
It's really good. I really enjoyed him in this. Next week
I'm also going to be solo, and I have no idea what to watch
There's not many movies coming out next week
let me know in the comments if you think that I should visit something that I missed Valerian or or
I almost said valkyrie
Dunkirk (is what I meant)
And let me know what you want to see next week
Regarding Tamra's just saw
Also, Tamra's never seen I need help on all fronts everyone. Check out my Twitter
I put polls up for series like Tamra's just saw and Tamara's Never-
I just said Tamara's Just Saw and Tamara's Never Seen
Tamara Just Saw and Tamara's Never Seen. Tamara, Tamara, Tamara...
Marsha, Marsha, Marsha
Thanks for stopping by see y'all next week. Bye
*BYE* >.<